new at 11 several schools in the
northwest valley say they don't want
dotties built on their street on tuesday
the city planning commission voting to
override a mandate to keep a gaming
establishment at least 1500 feet from a
school the dottie is set to go in is
just about 400 feet away from several
schools along rainbow right near anne in
the 95. those we spoke with say they
were already against this and after this
week's murder at adotti's they're even
more upset
we don't want it
here the business owners don't want it
here the people who are the patrons to
these businesses don't want it here so
why is why are they allowed to break the
law school systems right now are already
unsafe why would you ever make a change
or make a decision that brings crime
next to a school they need to realize
that a precedent needs to be set that
the code was there for a reason and that
they are elected
to uphold that
parents and school leaders say they have
gathered nearly 600 signatures opposing
the plans and they are urging the city
to reconsider you can read more about
their effort on our website